madame
during the past 70 years the president
of the french republic has relied on
very few constants at the international
level
times have changed
europe has evolved our continent is
again experiencing war
throughout these transformations your
devotion to our alliance and to our
friendship has remained and has helped
build trust that brought freedom and
prosperity to our continent since your
first state visit to france when you
were welcomed to paris by a generation
who alongside your army navy and air
force had fought for the freedom we now
enjoy
you have visited us many times
you have shared our joys
and seen the deep affection and
admiration that the people of france
have for you you have also visited the
graves where so many of your young men
lie
and since the respect and honor we
constantly pay to those who sent from
your homes to protect ours
you are the golden thread that binds our
two countries the proof of the
unwavering friendship between our
nations your first toast to one of my
predecessors rene koti reminded us that
trust and understanding should endure
forever
your words were matched by a lifetime of
devotion to our alliance
from the dark days when your family
welcomed general the girl in your home
to his joy to welcome you in his you
have been a constant presence and a
source of wisdom
for the leaders of our two countries
this year
the 70s of your reign we celebrate your
achievements
we are grateful for your courage and we
share the respect and love
that british people and commonwealth
have always shown you